PRESIDENT DOESN'T EVEN WANT TO
THINK ABOUT.
THANK YOU, MOLLY LINE.
LET'S GET SOME CONTEXT ON THE
PENNSYLVANIA RACE.
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME JOINS US TONIGHT.
THIS IS A DISTRICT THAT'S NOT
EVEN GOING TO EXIST NEXT YEAR.
IT'S ALL ABOUT BRAGGING RIGHTS
TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING THERE IS SO
MUCH BEING SPENT TO FILL BRIEFLY
A CONGRESSIONAL SEAT THAT THAT'S
ABOUT TO GO AWAY BECAUSE THE
PENNSYLVANIA SUPREME COURT
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICTING PLAN
THAT HAD BEEN DRAWN UP BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND REPLACED IT WITH
ONE THAT MAKES THIS ONE GO AWAY.
WHAT WE HAVE IS WE HAVE A
SPECIAL ELECTION TO FILL OUT AN
UNEXPIRED TERM IN A SEAT THAT
WON'T BE THERE ANYMORE.
THE CROSSCURRENTS IN THIS RACE
ARE ALMOST TOO NUMEROUS TO COUNT
ARE ALMOST TOO NUMEROUS TO COUN
COUNT.
IN ADDITION TO THE FACT THAT
IT'S A DISTRICT THAT'S ABOUT TO
DISAPPEAR, IT HAS BEEN A
MAJORITY DEMOCRATIC DISTRICT.
IN ADDITION, THE REPUBLICAN TIM
MURPHY WAS EXCUSED FROM
CONGRESS, EXCUSED HIMSELF FROM
CONGRESS AFTER A SEX SCANDAL
WHICH GENERALLY BODES WELL FOR
THE SUCCESSOR IN THE SAME PARTY.
NOT TO MENTION DEMOCRATS HAVE
COME UP WITH AN INTRIGUING
CANDIDATE.
YOUNG, ATTRACTIVE, TELEGENIC
MARINE VETERAN.
THIS COULD GO EITHER WAY.
>> John: 2016 THE PRESIDENT
WON THIS DISTRICT BY ALMOST 20
POINTS.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS EVEN CLOSE
THE FACT THAT THIS IS EVEN CLOS
CLOSE.
PEOPLE AREN'T EXPECTING THE
REPUBLICAN TO WALK AWAY WITH IT,
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
THE CANDIDATE, OR THE PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, IT'S HAS A COUPLE
THINGS TO ME.
ONE OF THEM IS THIS TREMENDOUS
ANTIPATHY AMONG DEMOCRATS MEANS
THEY ARE MOTIVATED AS THEY WOULD
NOT NORMALLY BE TO COME OUT AND
VOTE.
THIS IS A WAY TO REGISTER YOUR
OBJECTIONS TO DONALD TRUMP.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, AS I
MENTIONED, THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE IS KIND OF CUTE.
AND THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
THIS KIND OF A FRUMPY GUY.
THAT ADDS INTO THE MIX.
I DON'T THINK THAT IN A RACE
LIKE THIS WITH SO MANY
CROSSCURRENTS FOR AN ELECTION
THEY SAID IT'S GOING TO BE
REPEATED COME FALL, THAT YOU CAN
DRAW THAT MANY CONCLUSIONS FROM
IT.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WIN, THEY WILL
CLAIM THEY'VE GOT THE MOMENTUM
FOR A HUGE BLUE WAVE IN THE
FALL.
IF THE REPUBLICANS MANAGED TO
HOLD THE SEAT WITH THE PRESIDENT
HAVING COME IN OVER THE WEEKEND
AND CAMPAIGNED FOR THIS
CANDIDATE, YOU ARE GOING TO HEAR
MR. TRUMP SAYING IT WAS A BIG
WIN FOR HIM.